Tiger step back rib holds onto you your
limbs do come right off it's happened
many times gangs Garretson the [ __ ]
narc in that show the Rat Fink that's in
there him rollin along that shows full
rats right matter where your vibe is
where you're from when I grew up
those dudes benches those guys are
trouble right out there that guy he was
in Texas they let this out of the show
he was in Texas a few years before the
show went down he's got a tiger there at
a place called jungle land I think
something like that Rubick this is the
fat guy or the guy okay
turn state's evidence yes because they
both went state F right they both they
both him both turn and both set Joe up
to the max you know a whole lot of set
up there may be bad guys in Texas he's
hanging out he's got some chick there
he's like hey man did you get all right
cool dude he's knows and they're cool
you pet his nose snap grabs a chick by
the hand backs up arm I'm right out of
the shoulder booth
arms gone nobody's dead its high-end
EMTs that's your only chance is to get
in there and hemostat out the arm he
bleeds out and dies on the way to the
hospital no she's dead she was killed by
James's own ineptitude and his own show
off styling of what was going on his
tiger wrong type of page wrong type of
place wrong type of environment off
comes the arm of a girl lost his own
license was never allowed to have
animals again and he's totally on the
dark side he's then busted for illegally
I believe yet getting ahold of a lemur
and doing stuff and somehow and all that
that's the easy side it States evidences
Thurn there's a whole other huge story
of some kind of credit fraud and fake
banks and all kinds of other weird [ __ ]
that games Garretson and Jeff Jeff were
both being burned into turned on because
of Joe finding out the stories and
laying all that down I think some of
that animosity of insanity is what
helped get Joe on the outs with them
as Jeff was acquiring his zoo James is
there whatever he's doing for them with
them yeah hope things melting down and
in the process of that they bring this
hitman in and going hey I got this
bargain hitman dude who go and make a
transcontinental hit for you
for $3,000 how's that sound Joe at what
clown ism who thinks that way
who thinks bit man are introduced by new
friends who things hitmen are cheap and
who thinks that you just happen to meet
one it's also a maintenance dude on the
side I mean it was just
Joe's stressed-out melted down brain
going on but it just wasn't working out
well for him and he allowed himself to
the speed hold along and he was
infatuated with the illusion that Jeff
had something with a rented house and a
rented Ferrari and they complain was in
front of a plane
what is that what I was trying to
understand that when I was watching that
like what type of character is a Jeff
like who is he a con artist like where
do these exist outside of this business
as far as I know Jeff Jeff had no
business with animals before this you
know right before his you know soiree
maybe he met someone with a lion here
there because they just what is he like
he is Evel Knievel and Robbie Evil's son
one of their tech men front men for the
traveling org
there's a Huey Freeman line there's a
whole bunch of information about him
making all kinds of faith memorabilia
that's Evel Knievel stuff and all kinds
of forged sunglasses also for guys like
the color crazy purple guy with the
symbol that's his name heck I can't
believe a cat member's name
he's selling prints jackets memorabilia
sunglasses busts for all kinds of things
allegedly and all through that process
he was this guy that knew how to run
this con thing he and James Garretson
according to Joe for running these fake
credit card scams and doing stuff I
heard
oh no the truth that he's who paid for
John Finley spieth [ __ ] that ridiculous
mouth but if you looked online now
there's all kinds of pictures of him
with this perfect smile yeah seen it
normally looks like he has that big ol
smile there and that's how I always saw
him they made him remove his bridgework
to film him so he'd look like a Burnout
meth head but he always looks perfectly
like extra perfect teeth because he's
got big dental implant bridge
attachments there and they always need
him take his shirt off they're creating
that vibe no the same preset a little
chick with the screwed up arm look at
her at any other point
he's got the sleeve on the covers the
amputation she's got it inside of a coat
they've got it all laid out there like
some big floppy dick sittin in the
middle of the picture like oh yeah this
poor girl in a dump they've got her tied
up like in front of a damn dumpster
Glacius prick and sensationalism
[ __ ]
put her in that shot made her arm lay
out there and she's got it on the
steering wheel when she's driving of
course she doesn't drive like that
they're beginning drama